there's a reflection
[Music]
i mean that's bold
what if we take this and we use the most
cutting edge tools we can and we enhance
this as good as we can can we actually
compete with the magical enhanced
computer from csi
wait what just happened nick dude
someone just popped jordan coleman's
tires what enhanced
that niko enhanced
remember all those enhanced scenes from
like csi and
law order and ncis yeah how can i forget
it's like a full-on meme at this point
there
zoom in
scale up hold on second i'll enhance
enhance please you're gonna want to zoom
in and enhance i've always wanted to see
if us as vfx artists using the most
cutting edge of modern technology
can we actually compete with the magical
enhanced computer from csi you know even
with the modern technology we have now
i'm not convinced because it was always
just like fake in the shows you know it
was always just not actually a real
thing
let's magnify it see if we can get a
reflection off our eye
wait what
all right
this is a straight different picture
it's like front on now it's like we're
looking down at her and then it was like
this is not something we could just zoom
in unless the original had this
resolution although this type of jump
plausible in modern times we actually
have really good ai tools that upscale
images really well and we did a whole
video on this comparing the original
iphone 1 to the brand new iphone 13 last
fall essentially these ai upscaling
algorithms are trained on millions of
images and slowly learn to take any
image you give it and create new pixels
between the existing ones that increases
the resolution of the input image it's
informed by knowledge like let's say i
have a picture of ren's face but it's
really blurry if the ai knows how to
draw faces and be like well it's blurry
but i can guess that the eyeball looks
like this because i know what eyeballs
look like i know that these dark spots
here should be eyeballs so there's that
level of like
information going into this stuff but if
i were just to give it a
random thing
like a
a pixel and i said you know invent i
don't know what this is at all figure it
out now you're getting to the area where
there's like there's no there's no
previous knowledge that can help invent
that detail as for moments like these
and csi that's where they move into the
fantasy realm
[Music]
so now we're in like this hyper zoomed
in photo of this person's eye and we're
looking at a reflection of a guy in the
person's eye and now it's a basketball
i mean this is magic this is impossible
there's no way you can take a single
pixel that's one color
and like turn that into detail i mean
you can if you generate it yeah you can
generate you can like you can make up i
think the term is hallucinating your
computer can hallucinate the detail but
it's not actual detail like if you use
this as evidence it'd be literally the
same thing as an artist just going in
and drawing a basketball and being like
it's a basketball and they're like so
it's like i drew it and you're like so
it's like
so it's evidence
vix tickets were in section 203
see it's m26 and 28s all right there's a
crowd okay a crowd
okay that's actually pretty clever yeah
that
hold up you definitely would not be able
to do that
wash and wax we're looking at one pixel
and now that one pixel looks like this
or just words it's literally black magic
it's literally like inventing
detail out of nothing this is the
security camera at the underwear store
freeze there
so this is perhaps the most egregious
form of enhancement because they're like
looking on the other side
of
the picture what
but okay i feel like the movie gets away
with it because it's like it's all just
pure sci-fi under the guise of being
current tech you know it's still sci-fi
it's not realistic but it makes me
wonder if there are any imaging tools
out there that are like actually used by
police departments or in ports and stuff
like that
so this is image analysis forensic
software from a company called clonex so
this is the actual this is the real deal
this is the real stuff
okay hold up i'm actually legit
interested now you can see in this
example from a tutorial video there's a
blurry license plate and we can't really
see the number but it's not just a pixel
we're zooming in on there are plenty of
pixels here and there's data and this is
an example where there might be a
pattern and if you know the motion blur
direction and you have samples along
each you know position of the car there
and that in that motion blur there might
be a way to bring it back together
whoa n four four
zero j j d
i mean before i could just barely make
out that there's an n and now i can very
clearly see the next two characters
after that 44. it's like fancy
sharpening it's sharpening with a
directional blur it's like undoing like
if i take a pixel and i write a piece of
code to smear it
i can just do the opposite i can unsmear
something all right so here's another
example that's pretty crazy you think
this one's possible what no way
no way that's not possible that angle is
way too steep
oh they're gonna do a corner pin
undistort
wow
it was literally just a mush of pixels
that he enhanced and then undistorted
and now i can clearly read four eight
nine nine zero zero like this is not ai
here this is just solid math this is
like doing basic like harmonics and like
pattern recognition this is literally
sourcing it from the original data like
that data was technically there it was
just scrambled yes you can apply this
principle like anything i mean you've
seen potion seller right
potion seller
i want only your strongest potions
you can't handle my potions
they're too strong for you
[Music]
okay i've never seen that before but
that's what you're talking about he's
got like this weird post effect going on
that's distorting his face that in
theory we should be able to undo by just
applying the inverse distortion
so that's just the dude moving his head
around wow
that's actually working that's working
like really well
i mean honestly most of what enhancing
really comes down to is deep blurring
there's some really cool problem solving
happening with the software but at the
end of the day you are just de-blurring
and de-warping the image but csi pushes
this past the point of de-blurring into
the point where it's like the pixels
don't have any data to de-blur
bring his face up
all right here's a straightforward scene
where they're gonna enhance it with
their computer
we don't know what they enhance this
image to yet what if we take this and we
use the most cutting edge tools we can
and we enhance this as good as we can
and we're going to come back and compare
ourselves to the csi computer and see if
we can beat the csi computer okay 10
minutes i'll be right back
hey i'm filming you too yeah just to
make sure hey you feel me i'll film you
it's fine we'll just make sure that
everything is is on the up and up
everyone's upstairs doing csi type
analysis to see if they can enhance
video footage but have you ever wondered
whether you can enhance audio footage
well i have and i finally cracked it i
finally found a way to get an enhanced
audio experience like never before
courtesy of today's sponsor raycon
i know you've probably been used to a
subpar audio experience you've probably
been thinking jake i don't have the
money to pay top dollar to get a premium
audio experience for my earbuds well
guess what that problem is a thing of
the past courtesy of today's sponsor
raycon with their everyday earbuds they
provide a premium wireless earbud
experience for only about half the price
as the other guys now don't take my word
for it okay i know you're probably
wondering what other people think of
this and i'm gonna see if i can enhance
their audio experience right now
now i've been crunching the numbers and
one thing that's key to having an
enhanced audio experience is the in-ear
fit of your earbud and ray-cons have the
perfect in-ear fit and guess what they
also have eight hours of play time with
a 32-hour rechargeable case i mean these
things just keep going they have over 49
000 5 star reviews online
now i want you to put these in your ear
nico raycons have
both noise isolation mode and awareness
mode meaning that you can get that
ambient sound from people around you and
if you don't want to hear them you just
turn on noise isolation mode and you get
an even better experience
they're getting it i can hear them
i can hear they're getting it all right
it seems like the entire crew was really
enjoying their enhanced audio experience
i don't know if you noticed but they
were really honed in on what i was
saying and that's because of raycon's so
if you guys are interested in getting a
pair of raycons for yourself you get
fifteen percent off just by clicking the
link in the description below just go to
byracon.com corridor crew i'm actually
i'm gonna put these in
and uh if i hear anyone typing in by
raycon.com corridor crew
oh
gregory i can hear you gregory
so the only thing i know about this
enhancement is that they're going to try
to pull a reflection off of the
sunglasses so first things first i'm
just going to bring in the file to after
effects my favorite photo editing
program
let's try adding some levels let's
brighten that up something like that
just kind of get as much of that detail
back i feel like i've kind of pushed
after effects to the limit here and i
need the help of some computer
magic
so i'm going to use topaz gigapixel we
use it on the iphone video this is like
literally the embodiment of enhance like
this is the modern
actual equivalent of doing that there's
a few different ai models that kind of
focus on various things like low
resolution is focused on just generally
upscaling it from something that was not
very much to begin with lines is more
for like architecture and landscapes
and so
enhance enhance
enhance
oh hey hey that actually kind of did
something there look at this so here's
the original and then if i let it update
his face becomes so much clearer
what is this reflection wait dude dude i
think there's something there you
cracked the case you're right i think i
did correct the case
dude i know i know who the suspect is i
know who the suspect is alright time to
go show nico
[Music]
nico i solved the case you did yeah i
found the suspect wow i'm actually
really amazed i was able to pull a
reflection
so not too bad not too bad but wait a
minute what's that reflection on his
glasses yeah what is that reflection in
his glasses evidence oh
wow it was dragon ball z the whole time
that's permissible in court
that's actually the nance isn't bad it's
not too bad but again it's in all the
texture and detail we're seeing is
invented all the lines are being
exaggerated and it still is keeping some
of those aliased lines in the background
and along his face i i turned on the
face enhancement option which
tells it okay we're looking at a face
apply some of the facial recognition
stuff for the upscaling so it's able to
actually add some of that texture detail
around his nose there and along his
cheeks and lips and that's something
that just simply scaling it up we
wouldn't have gotten but i think it's
safe to say that this is like the
furthest modern technology can push the
idea of enhancing this is like literally
as far as we can push it without
full-on inventing and rendering
something to be in there i'm excited to
actually see the original shot in the
context of the show so that i can prove
you right all along there's a reflection
oh that's what i missed out on was the
the little
the cross hair wait there you go
what
what wait what even was that
they didn't even try to like make it
look like part of the reflection where'd
all that orange come from
they're looking at all this blue stuff
and then all of this orange came in man
that's magic that's just i mean that's
bull
yeah
it's like that's not magic that's just
them being like and uh
they're supposed to see this so throw
that in there it's honestly kind of
crossing the line from at all having any
possibility of just being dumb
suspect was last seen southbound on
hunter street
by the scene
witnesses describe a square face and he
was
a-list
wait what just happened nick dude
someone just popped jordan coleman's
tires whoa
wait don't we have a security camera
we do yeah we do renda white
why are you dressed like a cop already
dude it's it's how i roll man did you
know that this was happening i mean i
mean
kinda
so you're looking at like you know crazy
magical csi footage but what about
actually doing real security footage so
we took our security camera nick put on
a mask of another face just a paper mask
a celebrity face and we're going to try
to identify who this is using our tools
to enhance this footage but first off
let's just look at the raw footage so
there's gonna be a celebrity popping
tires on our street and we have no idea
so far it's just this white blowing out
oh wait a minute okay
wait exposure problem
okay we have to enhance this can we like
maybe take a screen grab of that and
just zoom in
maybe we can see it if we just zoom in
okay
why does he look like freaking bilbo
baggins when he's jealous of the mithril
we're literally doing the enhanced thing
right now
[Music]
wow
is that nick cage no it's not in a cage
wait what
what what
wow
sam who is this we've enhanced it with
a.i
john candy or something right
wow
i mean that was close all right so the
first one didn't work at all it invented
a face and it was no one and so we chose
a slightly different frame because it's
video we can choose which frames to you
know look at we're running it through
topaz labs gigapixel once more
oh it's like hurting my collarbone from
laughing too
all right so we got a hot tip through
our
tit hotline
and we know a couple things
we know that it is a male actor a-list
celebrity
and
we've apparently brought in an expert
witness
what do you need ren
i don't know
what is that who is that who is that i
mean it looks like wren
niko could you do me a favor real quick
could you enhance that uh sure
oh whoa
that was so creepy that's creepy because
i did punch holes in the eyes oh
yeah so i could see
so he's got it looks like he has a big
dimple chin he's got an extremely square
face
so there's no beard that i can tell
either whoever it is has to have very
deep like eye sockets because those are
some dark eyes
we should organize a lineup here
yeah we need to line up this is how the
cops find criminals is they pull up a
low resolution photo and then they think
of famous celebrities
and they
line up those famous celebrities and
just pick one out of a hat
harrison ford bruce willis steve carell
mel gibson he would do some shady stuff
is it woody harrelson
enhanced he gets that nico enhanced matt
damon wait matt damon matt damon yeah
damien i can see a little bit of matt
damon in there not he doesn't have the
dimple it has to have the chin nipple
that's the most refined part could it be
our boy ben
benny flick oh he's got a big chin butt
okay that reminds me of mark ruffalo
does that not look like mark ruffalo to
you is it hulk mark ruffalo dude it
might be the hulk nick
i i don't is the criminal in this lineup
yes what what
all right i'm ready to make my vote
woody harrelson okay
woody harrelson
i don't know man this is tough i might
have to go mark ruffalo look at mark
ruffalo's crow magnum features dude i
see the deep sockets right there dude
he's got that square head i find myself
starting to agree more with dean here
you guys brought me in here for a reason
i think it's mark ruffalo
all right but if he dies the blood is on
your hands that's fine all right mark
ruffalo you're under arrest for popping
jordan's tire mark ruffalo all right so
guys we just got a call and the tire
popper actually just confessed and we're
bringing him in right now
i can't wait to see this scumbag
[Music]
it is mark ruffalo
oh my god
that's so creepy
dude wait we nailed it no we didn't
you guys didn't nail it but you got it
so i chose it because i thought the eyes
were very recognizable the deep eye
sockets like dean was saying are kind of
recognizable he's like mid bite at lunch
dude he's like
well gentlemen my work here is done he's
a hero thank you thank you dean see you
guys around see you later
so in all honesty
this we are way on face
this does not help at all what happens
when
a court case comes up and exactly what
we just went through ends up becoming
real evidence and they're trying to use
an actual upscaled image that's using
some of that generated detail in the
court of law
is that is that like
acceptable i think you have to be really
careful with that machine learning
algorithms invent detail they imagine it
they hallucinate it and they're informed
so it's it appears to be in the right
spot but as we saw in like the eyeballs
and lips were overlaid on these low-res
pictures like
that's effectively what's you know
what's happening with various like
machine learning programs as we saw with
clonix there are actual ways you can do
forensics or images and i think i think
the distinction is at least in my
opinion
if you're going to take images to court
and enhance them they need to be
enhanced with a mathematical formula
that does just basic math
transformations the data that's already
there in other words the data there can
be manipulated and reorganized and
patterned but you can't add new data i
think the main conclusion we can take
away from this is that the enhancement
shows like csi actually use is not
admissible in court their whole
foundation is wrong man this makes me
want to like investigate more sort of
tropes like this out of movies and shows
so if you've got any suggestions leave a
comment down below we'll check them out
this was a really fun video to do yeah
this is fun this is i've really wanted
to do this science experiment for a long
time yeah you mentioned this video
months ago and we were just finally
getting around to actually doing it i'm
so glad we did also subscribe because
next week we're gonna satisfy you